Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going
to explain an Indonesian comedy-drama film
called “Too Handsome to Handle.” Spoilers
ahead! Watch out and take care!
The Mas family has been good-looking for
several generations. They are admired by many
because of their beauty which in turn makes
them a lot of money. The eldest son, Okis,
is an internet influencer. He has millions
of followers because of his looks and is also
considered a love guru who helps men impress
their crushes. The father, Pakar used to be a
heartbreaker who dated more than twelve hundred
girls before meeting their mother. Meanwhile,
the mother can also be considered handsome because
of her masculine features and an obvious mustache.
Lastly, the protagonist, Kulin is the youngest
son and the most attractive of them all.
The family has gotten used to their life as people
with good looks. Except for Kulin, who struggles
to live normally because of his handsomeness.
He often wishes he was only mildly attractive;
that way, he could go out without being chased by
a crowd of women every time. Girls go crazy, pass
out, pull their hair, and often get nose bleeds
on getting a look at his attractive face.
As a result, he has never had genuine interaction
with a girl. He avoids going out in public as much
as possible and has been homeschooled till now.
Kulin has no friends he can talk to other than his
pet fish. He often plays cards with it and talks
to it out loud. His family watches him through a
camera in worry. They want him to have a normal
teenage life and try their best to help him.
Okis frequently shows him pictures of girls,
trying to hook him up with someone. However,
Kulin says that his type in girls is someone
who doesn’t like him. He wants to be seen for
his personality and interest, not his face.
When nothing works to motivate Kulin to go out,
the family takes it a step further. They
plan to fake financial problems and guilt him
into going to a school. One night when Kulin
wakes up to drink water, his parents pretend
to be worried about their finances. They
dramatically declare that they will only
eat scrambled eggs for breakfast until they earn
enough money for Kulin’s homeschooling. He feels
awful to be causing his parents so much trouble.
The next morning, he declares that he will be
going to school for the upcoming semester. The
family is overjoyed until he mentions that he will
only go to an all-boys school. Although they would
have preferred him to be able to talk to girls,
they are happy to take one step at a time.
A few days later is Kulin’s first day at an
actual school. Okis drops him off on his bike
but Kulin doesn’t take his helmet off. He plans
to wear it the entire day to hide the fact he
is handsome. However, the plan backfires when
the helmet grabs more attention than he intended
to. Kulin quietly sits down in the last seat but
is called out by the class bully Sidi and his
minions. When the teacher enters the classroom,
she too is surprised to see a guy with
a helmet. She urges him to take it off
right that instant. Although reluctant, Kulin has
no way but to oblige. He slowly takes the helmet
off in a dramatic way, revealing his face.
In the following scene, the teacher is being
loaded into an ambulance. It turns out that she
started to nosebleed and hyperventilate because
of Kulin’s beauty. The other kids complain to the
principal that the new student is too handsome
to handle. Kulin runs through the hallway to go
back home but is tripped by one of the bullies.
They bring him to the school’s storeroom and
introduce themselves like they are power rangers.
They are called the Tiga Tak, a group of three
bullies led by Sidi, the principal’s son. After
the over-the-top introduction, they reveal
that they need Kulin’s help to ask a girl
out for prom. The group has been in the senior
year of school for the past three years. They
refuse to graduate until Sidi goes to the prom
with the most beautiful girl of the BBM school,
Amanda. However, she only accepts requests from
handsome men so the group wants Kulin to deliver
the promposal. They assign an innocent guy,
Kibo, to help Kulin and lead the way. Kibo has
also been a victim of their pranks in the past
and is obliged to do what the bullies say.
Afterward, Kulin goes to the principal’s
office with Kibo to make an official complaint
about bullying in school. Kibo knows what the
outcome will be but he still accompanies Kulin.
The principal is troubled by his son refusing to
graduate. Since Kulin’s beauty gives him a chance
to take Amanda to the prom, the principal
wants them to do whatever the bullies say.
That evening, Kulin and Kibo decide to
complete the task the next day and get
rid of the responsibility. Kibo is the first
person who has shown kindness to Kulin, unrelated
to his beauty. Although the day didn’t go as
planned, he is happy to have gained a friend.
The next morning, they go to the BBM school where
the girls smell the presence of the boys. They are
strict about not allowing ugly boys to enter the
school premises. Hence, when they notice Kulin
wearing a helmet, the entire school asks him to
take it off. In a climactic scene, Kulin takes the
helmet off and mayhem ensues among the girls.
Only a few hours later, the news makes it to the
television. Clips of girls crying, bleeding
through their noses, getting possessed,
and jumping around are being shared all
around social media. Kulin starts being
known as the “too handsome to handle” guy. The
hottest student of the BBM school and model
named Amanda also hears the news and is instantly
smitten by Kulin. He is the first guy who matches
in beauty and status with her. She immediately
makes it her mission to impress him.
When the news becomes huge, a crowd of girls
gathers in front of the Mas residence. The
family starts charging them money for a house
tour. Kulin, who is hiding in the streets, sees
his family on the news. He feels betrayed and used
by his own people. When they call him, he refuses
to come home and feels even sadder when his pet
fish is mishandled and killed by the tourists.
He is now on the roof of a building hiding from
the maniacs chasing him in the streets. Suddenly,
a girl appears behind him and inquires if he
is going to jump off the roof. Kulin looks
at her in shock because she doesn’t bleed
from her nose or pass out on seeing him.
The girl refuses to talk and simply walks away.
Kulin is so nervous that he can hardly speak.
The encounter makes his day a lot better.
A while later, he calls Kibo who picks him up and
invites him to his home. He and his grandmother
welcome Kulin to stay for as long as he wants.
On walking into Kibo’s room, he sees two rare
collectible playing cards and is amazed by
them. They realize that they share several common
interests and playing card collection is one of
them. The following day, they visit the all-girls
school to look for the girl from yesterday. While
they are at it, they also meet Amanda and give her
the files of the promposal sent by Sidi. Amanda
pretends to be unimpressed by Kulin’s beauty, but
after he leaves, her nose bleeds profusely.
Kulin sees his crush on the stairs but the other
girls surrounding him do not allow him to meet
her. For the next few days, Kibo and Kulin do
everything together and become best friends.
One afternoon, Kibo takes Kulin to play futsal
where he frequently goes to meet his crush; Rere.
After the match, Kulin notices the girl
from the roof working at a shop nearby.
He cannot help but stare at her. Just then,
Kibo arrives and introduces Rere to him. Kulin
discovers that she is also Kibo’s crush who he was
talking about earlier. The two seem to be pretty
close which makes Kulin jealous. He can hardly
fall asleep that night because the feeling is
new and confusing to him. Then, he remembers Okis
is a love guru and fixes a meeting with him.
When they meet the following morning, Okis
breaks down crying tears of happiness. He
had been waiting for the day to give his brother
advice on girls. Kulin has forgiven his family
for selling him out to his fans because if that
had not happened, he would have never met Rere.
The brothers then go shopping for groceries
while Okis lists out the points of things
Kulin should do to impress his crush.
As Kulin follows Okis’s suggestions,
he registers he is far from knowing Rere like
Kibo knows her. But he still doesn’t want to
give up on his first love. One afternoon,
Amanda comes to the boys’ school and hands
Kulin an invitation for her birthday. Alongside
it, she also gives him a phone as a gift.
Later that day, Kibo, Kulin, and Rere go to
karaoke. Eventually, Rere and Kulin get to
sing together. While Kulin is excited to duet
with her, Rere only focuses on Kibo. He soon
registers that she also likes Kibo back. The
revelation makes his heart crumple in jealousy.
So, when Kibo is not around, he bluntly asks
her if she has a crush on him. Initially,
Rere denies it but when Kulin lies about Kibo
being in love with Amanda, her face drops. Her
expression is enough to confirm his suspicions.
After returning home, Kulin calls Amanda and asks
her for a favor. She happily agrees to do anything
he says. The next day, several people gather at
the venue to celebrate her birthday. When Kulin
and Kibo arrive, Amanda welcomes them. Strangely
enough, she seems to be more interested in Kibo
than in Kulin. She even pulls him aside to talk
to him in private. At the same time, Rere arrives
at the party and sees Amanda kissing Kibo.
Heartbroken, she runs outside. Taking
advantage of her vulnerability,
Kulin confesses his feelings for her. Rere
thanks him but claims that she never saw him as
someone more than a friend. Even after conspiring
against his only best friend, Kulin gets nothing
in return. The group of bullies also see Amanda
kissing Kibo and are enraged with jealousy and
anger. They beat Kibo up for it while Kulin
watches from nearby, too scared to interfere.
Later, he brings Kibo home and dresses his wounds
alongside his grandmother. Only after seeing him
moan in pain, does Kulin realize that he has
made a huge mistake. The next day, Kibo gives
him a legendary card from his card collection
that Kulin had been wanting for a long time.
Guild-ridden, Kulin confesses to everything
wrong he has done till now. Kibo is shocked
and hurt by the betrayal. He claims that he would
have left Rere if he knew Kulin liked her too.
The words do nothing but hurt Kulin even
more. At last, Kibo orders him to get out
of the house immediately. Knowing that he
is in the wrong, Kulin simply leaves.
He finally returns home after a month. His family
is overjoyed but the same cannot be said for
Kulin. He locks himself in his room and doesn’t
talk to anyone. But most of all, he misses his
best friend. The two bump into each other at times
but never share anything more than a glance.
At home, Kulin’s mother is worried about his
well-being. She approaches him one night and gives
him his pet fish that never died. She also tells
him that he can go back to being homeschooled
if that is what he prefers. The family only wants
his happiness and is ready to do anything for it.
Kulin, touched by her words, realizes that he
has people in his life who are rooting for his
success. This motivates him to make things right
between him and Kibo. The next morning, he runs
to Rere and tells her everything. Following
that, he goes to Kibo and tries to apologize.
Although Kibo dismisses him at first, when asked
about Rere, he starts to describe how much he
loves her. Kulin shows him that Rere was listening
to him on the phone the entire time. That way,
he mends their relationship and goes
back to being both their friend.
A few days later, they all go to prom together.
Kibo’s date is Rere while Kulin’s date is Amanda.
As expected, Kulin and Amanda win the title
of prom king and queen. Kulin hears a girl
comment that he is only mildly handsome
and is instantly drawn to her, indicating
the start of a new relationship.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thanks for watching.